Eric after you won Emmys for from the
earth to the moon and Band of Brothers
you ended up in a position where you
begin to pitch ideas can you tell us
about that period of your life yeah so
there's a certain point where I kind of
had a little bit of an aim in terms of
being a writer that my agents could get
out there to page based especially bit
after Band of Brothers and I signed at a
certain point I transitioned from a
small agency to its EAA that which is
the biggest agency and I had I had these
you know pretty aggressive agents in the
TV literary department who were like you
know we can get you out on meetings and
you know you can pitch ideas - you know
networks and try and create your own
series so for for several years that was
kind of my main focus I had a few jobs
where I work on staff on other people's
shows but but it was really come up with
an idea email the idea like in a two or
three sentence log line to my agent and
then wait for a response and see if they
think it's worth doing anything with
what I really learned was a lot of it
once you have an agent if you're trying
to go pitch ideas or even if you're just
writing on spec they want to they want
to know that it's a worthwhile idea
before that you know you're gonna pursue
it further or they're gonna send it out
or send you out with it
so so what I really learned a lot about
was what makes a viable TV series idea
because I was doing it for a living and
I was coming with all these ideas and
most of them my agents weren't that
interested in and they would shoot down
for various reasons so it was like I
have to first get it past my own
Representatives my own employees so to
speak but I understood why because they
their reputation hinges on their only
bothering people with ideas from clients
that they actually think really have a
chance right so it doesn't look good for
them if a studio or producer keeps
getting phone calls from them saying you
got to read this script or hear this
pitch and it's something they don't like
so so I learned and eventually there
would be an idea that they would like
just that little logline version and
then they would set me up on meetings
with production companies you know pods
producer overall deals that they would
represent the agency would represent all
these different production companies
that had deals at different studios and
you know sometimes I go out and pitch
the same idea to a different producer at
every
one of the like five or six studios and
hopefully they would like it and if
somebody liked it then the next step is
you pitch it to the studio that they are
affiliated with and if the studio likes
it then you would pitch it to network
and studios usually like to pitch to
their sister networks if they have one
which most of them do these days so
there was a lot of you know first we got
to go to our home network and then if
they don't buy it then you can go to the
other networks so you know so it's a lot
of swings and misses when you're doing
that I think for for most people
where you know the ideas you have that
your agents like you may not get a
producer their likes or your producer
may like it but you can't sell it to
network like but if you go the whole
distance and the network likes it then
they pay you to write a pilot script and
that's kind of like the whole goal
initially is to get a deal to write a
pilot where they're paying you all
you've done is come up with a pitch and
you know they're gonna pay you to write
it as you go which means they have a
certain amount of control over it
because now they own it and they're
gonna give you notes all along the way
but as a writer who's always writing on
spec and may or may not sell anything
it's great tax to be paid while you're
doing it so that was kind of my first
experience of that other than working on
those miniseries did you think it was
going to be or your pitches would be
received differently coming off the
success of these two shows did you feel
that it would have been easier or was it
actually less difficult than you
imagined no it was definitely harder
than I imagined when I first started
pitching ideas for series I had no idea
what I was doing and I just came up with
these ideas without any real knowledge I
mean I'd watch TV my whole life I had
won two Emmys for these mini series on
HBO but those were very different from a
like normal drama series right and
ongoing you know scripted series that
isn't based on history is very different
from a miniseries based on history so
what I learned pitching to my agents at
CAA whether it was a full sit-down
here's my lengthy idea or a short log
line in an email was that they didn't
like most of the ideas that came up with
and they would that they would tell me
I'm aware my agent said said once you
know they're gonna
you don't really understand television
if you picture it was a big learning
curve for me to - and it really really
helped me realize for the first time I
may have to come up with a lot of
different ideas that I actually spent
some time on to get to one that the
professionals who represent me are gonna
like enough to want to send out to the
industry and remind me again what is
pods stand for so a pod is a producer
overall deal which just means a
production company that has a deal with
one of the studios whether it's for
features or TV or both and so as a
writer when you pitch something to your
agents and they like it usually the
first step is they wanna then have you
pitch it to one of the pods that that
agency represents if you had to put a
number on the amount of ideas that you
pitched what would that number be if it
included idea that I just had like a two
or three sentence long line that I sent
to my agents or somebody dozens and
dozens for sure you know maybe a hundred
maybe maybe a little less than that and
those were mostly post Emmy yeah yeah
yeah I mean I wasn't really in a
position where anybody was interested in
me pitching anything before those two
miniseries that establish me as a writer
so there were no opportunities or
interests but once once you're
established enough that you've done
something people think is good and and
you know if you've won awards that's
helpful then suddenly it's like okay do
you have ideas or if you've worked on
something successfully for many years
like on staff of a series and you've you
know risen up you know in the food chain
of the series to a higher level over a
period of years that's when the studios
and the network's and the agency even
start to be more interested in you as
somebody who might have your own idea
for a show so I didn't have any interest
in me for that until after Band of
Brothers but then I had a lot of
interest in a lot of people were
interested in meeting me and so forth so
I became kind of like a flavor of the
month there for a while where I was
being sad to meet with all these
different executives and production
companies sometimes just for general
meetings like who are you nice to meet
you what kind of stuff do you want to do
and then sometimes pitch meetings where
I have an official idea that I'm coming
in to talk to them about
so most of the ones most of the ideas I
would pitch to my agents would die there
and they wouldn't send me out with them
anymore but the ones that they like then
I would end up with a production company
and then sometimes you make
relationships with those people and they
want to know what else you have and and
you kind of get the ball rolling but
what I learned was it really does start
with your representative whether you
have a manager an agent or both if they
don't like it it's probably not going
anywhere so you kind of have to impress
them first and sometimes they're the
toughest ones to impress I felt when you
would go out on the meetings that were
just sort of like a meet and greet
did you realize like the impact that
those quick meetings would have did you
realize they were kind of like sizing
you up to see is this someone we can
work with whether his ideas are
brilliant or not you know those kind of
general meetings some people some people
jokingly call them free water because
that's the only thing they ever comes of
it it should be free bottled water while
you're sitting there having a meeting
because they can seem pointless they can
seem like it's just hi how are you and I
used to put a face to the writing sample
we read or the script we the project we
saw that you wrote or whatever so it is
that they seem a little bit vague
sometimes the general meetings if you
don't have anything to pitch it's
probably always better if you have some
things you're working on that you can
refer to obliquely without really
pitching them so that they'll be like oh
that sounds kind of interesting when
you've worked that out let's hear more
about that you know but I never knew
what came with those general meetings
other than I suppose there were some
where my ages were like oh they really
liked you and when we have something to
pitch they're definitely gonna be on the
list of someone to take it to so I
suppose for them there is a little bit
of a screening process the production
company there they want to know that
you're good in a room you know that
you're articulate that you're somebody
that they think could pitch something
successfully to a network because
obviously that's part of the job so I
suppose they're auditioning me for that
but I wasn't really super aware of what
exactly was going on maybe that's magic
here is he's coming he's going there
were more than one option is what I'm
saying which was nice that's great how
long did this pitching phase of your
life last or is it still going on well
I'm in theory it could happen at any
but but there was a period where I was
really actively doing that which was
kind of like I would say like a five
year period or so like after Band of
Brothers and kind of pre-strike I
remember that I sold a pitch right
before the strike and was writing the
script when we went on strike and then
that project didn't happen because the
strike kind of they like kind of killed
a lot of deals during the strike so I
kind of see that as a as a demarcation
period and that was leading up to that
was a pier where I was really doing that
as the my main focus pitching one-hour
TV ideas and they were always lighter
comedic one hours because I always felt
I was a comedy person I'd always my
start was in comedy and then I became
known for this very dramatic historical
stuff which meant I could be sold into
the industry writing that but I never
really wanted to like write legal dramas
and stuff like that so I was always
pitching ideas that were kind of like
almost too comedic to be a one-hour and
maybe that's why they didn't you know I
didn't sell it's nice I might have
because I wasn't really a procedural
writer or like a dark thriller II drama
type of writer the kind of stuff I was
pitching at that time there wasn't
necessarily a lot of those kind of shows
with that kind of tone on the air also
they probably weren't the greatest ideas
I'm not gonna say that it was just
because it was the wrong fit but but
yeah about five years what was the
biggest takeaway whether it's just take
the water if you're offered or what what
was the biggest lesson from that
probably the biggest takeaway is really
what eventually led to this book I wrote
called the idea which is that you gotta
come up with a lot of ideas to come up
with one that you could actually sell or
that would sell if you wrote the script
because I really did see that this isn't
easy at all I mean you can look at TV
and go oh there's all these different
kind of TV shows I can just come with an
idea for a show and it's a viable idea
all I have to do is write it or get the
right person to hear it and and I mean I
wasn't probably that naive but I was
more naive than I am now because I
really learned that it's a lot of work
and develop an idea for a show and
chances are they're gonna say yeah
here's why that isn't going to work or
why we're
that interested or why there been other
shows kind of like that or that either
were successful and so you're coming too
late to the party or they weren't
successful which shows us that kind of
show doesn't really work and so probably
the biggest takeaway was just like yeah
this this is an easy I see like you know
you get paid pretty well when you break
through with something but there's it's
very very easy to have a lot of lean
times where you're not selling anything
even though you're working at it pretty
hard
do you almost think it was better that
you didn't know just because some people
when they know what the odds are they
won't try something you know in very
bright people but they they just feel
like well it's not even worth trying
well there was no way that I was going
to not try it because at that point I
had reached a real height I mean I just
won my second Emmy and had these two big
miniseries I had work with Tom Hanks for
years and he still had projects for me
to like do with him and stuff at
Playtone so it wasn't like there was no
chance I was gonna be afraid to try it
was more like oh they want to hear my
ideas now great okay I'll come up with
ideas and then we're like a little
humbling that oh it isn't so easy but it
wasn't like a fear of trying going in I
was just kinda like great I'm I'm mr.
impressive Hollywood writer now that
people want to work with so so I'll come
up with some ideas and we'll see where
it goes I wasn't super confident but I
wasn't like scared of it I would say
because it was more like good things are
happening oh okay let's do this now
great exciting Eric we have a question
from Chloe Louisa and Chloe asks what
goes into a successful series pitch and
what are some tips to really sell your
ideas so what I've learned is that a
successful series pitch it focuses on
the series not just the pilot that's one
of the big things because people tend to
like come up with an idea for what's
going to happen in the pilot episode and
they want to pitch that in great detail
but they may not really understand what
a typical episode would look like after
the pilot and so the other thing that
writers tend to do is they feel like oh
I know the long arcs of this show it's
gonna start here and in season five it's
going to be here and these are these
things that are going to take many many
episodes to play out and while there is
a place for that in a pitch I think
writers tend to err too much on the side
writers that are just kind of starting
out
on the side of those kind of long arcs
and what can be more important and is
easy for them to miss is yeah but what
is a typical episode look like what's a
typical one hour or half-hour of this
show I think that's what the listener is
kind of trying to most understand
because they're picturing something
there's going to be these endless
episodes up hopefully and each episode
has to have its own beginning middle and
end and not just be a small piece of a
longer story it has to have its own
story
in fact it probably's gonna have
multiple stories in it because a typical
TV episode has maybe two three four
different stories going on with a
different main character who has a
problem or goal that week and that's
gonna build and escalate over the course
of that half hour or hour at the end
it's going to resolve and so you're kind
of coming up with a template of what a
typical episode looks like when you come
up with a pitch so you want to be able
to communicate that template in a
compelling way so that they can sort of
imagine okay there's gonna be endless
hours of this and I can see the kind of
things that are gonna happen in a
typical episode the kind of problems and
conflicts that are gonna be the grist
for stories which characters are gonna
get stories what are those characters
main life issues problems desires and
conflicts that are gonna lead to stories
because a story is a problem a desire a
conflict that someone is actively trying
to resolve right it's usually building
and complicating and then reaching some
sort of climax before it's resolved so a
lot of it is also about character is you
want obviously have compelling
characters that feel believable and
entertaining and you know some somewhat
original that but they need something to
do they need something that's gonna
create endless hell for them essentially
so what is the hell that's almost like
the biggest question what puts your
characters in hell what's the thing
they're grappling with every single week
I mean Ozark the cartel is gonna kill us
unless we do this very difficult thing
and we might get killed or go to jail
trying to do that thing so it's like
figuring out what that is and that's the
main thing you're communicating there's
this big sort of problematic situation
that affects everyone on this show that
everyone's involved in in some way and
then we have these specific interesting
characters who are part of that whether
personal problems and conflicts along
the way so understanding all of that and
being able to communicate that to me is
kind of like the core of any pitch for a
series so you're saying most beginning
writers may they want to write let's
just use this as an example the pilot
episode of big little lies but then they
don't figure out all the other episodes
and all the stories and arcs and three
acts that are going to be in those other
episodes yeah it's not that you have to
figure out every episode that's like way
too much work to be doing in advance
like every story in every episode it's
more that you need that sort of
franchise's the word that sometimes use
which is the endlessly repeatable story
generating situation right so you want
to know something about what's happening
in your pilot and something about where
things might be evolving over the course
of say the first season or first and
second season or whatever but almost
more important than that is
understanding how in a typical hour or a
typical half-hour of this series here or
who might hear here's the the main
characters that are mostly going to be
the ones we're following and here's the
kind of stuff they're involved in the
kind of problems that they're trying to
resolve you don't have to know what they
are specifically but you have to kind of
have a sense of what they're made from
you know what's causing stories to
happen you know every week on this show
what is that thing that's that's
creating endless conflict difficulty and
a desire to resolve a problem and that's
you know to me that's the main thing
that tells me what it shows about just
like in a feature film the logline is
basically telling you what's the main
problem the main external difficulty
that the person we're following is
trying to resolve that's really
important it's gonna take the whole
movie to resolve it's about the problem
at the center of the story so it's
really the same thing with a series only
it's it's it's got to be ongoing stories
that are gonna go on and on and on many
stories dozens and dozens even hundreds
of stories you want to feel like this
has the potential for I know last
interview we had with you we talked a
lot about your book which was brand new
at that time and the book is the idea
the seven elements of a viable story for
screening stage or fiction
not sure if we asked you this before but
how much of the book is dedicated to
developing the character and how much of
it is dedicated developing plot it's a
good question you know it's really its
concept driven almost more than
character or plot character or plot is
all part of the overall concept but the
book is really about there's these seven
different elements that you want to make
sure your idea possesses so and those
seven elements describe the problem at
the heart of the story so the problem
has to be punishing and relatable and
original and believable and
life-altering and entertaining and
meaningful those are the 7th acronyms of
problem so each one of those seven
things has to do with plot and character
you know you want your characters to be
original in some way you want your
plotting to be original in some way but
most importantly you want your concept
to be original in some way the concept
that kind of holds it all together once
you have an idea that meets all the
criteria that you've laid out in your
book how do you go about structuring
that idea into a screenplay well a lot
of people I mean I've worked with
clients as a coach you know consultant
and help people do this and help guide
them through the process but I also do
it myself as a writer and I do think
that the save the cat book and its tools
are helpful I mean I my favorite thing
about saving the cat really are the 10
genres and working with and they each
have like five subgenres each that he
goes into in the second save the cat
book saved the cat goes to the movies
those genres I think are super helpful
and very original and revolutionary for
writers coming up with ideas for a movie
so I highly recommend those but he also
has the beach heat which is the thing
that saved the cats most known for which
is the 15 point structural paradigm
which I think was Blake Snyder building
on other paradigms people had for 3x
structure going back to probably
Aristotle but certainly Syd field and
other people's sense that and I think he
came up with some really good ideas for
here's what the first half of act 2 of a
movie were usually looks like and you
know the second half of back to usually
looks like and here's what the second
half of act 1 tends to look like let me
came up with fun names for these
different structural beats or sections
in a movie so I think that is a helpful
tool some people don't like it and you
know
or have a love/hate relationship with
trying to like fulfill especially when
it's like it has to happen on this page
or that page which I'm not super strict
about but but I do think he had some
pretty good arguments for why he fell
this is a good page Langer this is a
good place in the movie for certain
things to happen so anyway when you do
up one of those beat sheets it ends up
being like a four-page document I think
ideally where so what that means is
you're not spelling out every single
scene you're not figuring out every
single thing that happens in your movie
yet because that would take ten or
fifteen pages there's no way to really
do that in four pages if you're trying
to do that in four pages and I've seen
people do it often with the note they're
gonna get back is this isn't enough for
a movie there's not enough scenes here
there's not enough that it's happening
for this to fill two hours so it's
really about kind of summarizing the key
sections of the movie and then the key
points like the midpoint and the
breaking neck - and the brain acts three
which are just moments you know you kind
of figure out what those moments are and
then you summarize the sections in
between so you kind of have an overview
of the structure so that was one of
Blake's Blake Snyder's big contributions
to the world and and I and I think it's
helpful so I I will use that as one
method for kind of working toward a
structure would you say most of the
writers of screenwriting books and
teachers it's basically all the same but
they they name things in a different
fashion it's just their style of
presenting it I think there is some
truth to that that people are a lot of
times saying the same things in
different books and different paradigms
for story and screenwriting but I also
think people do come at it differently
and sometimes have different conclusions
about you know some of the precepts that
they come up with I mean like for
instance the dramatical theory of story
which I've played with a lot over the
years has a pretty different and
specific take on how stories work
compared to you know save the cat and
like the hero's journey the Christopher
Fogle book that is my understanding is
that's a certain kind of story he's
talking about which is a hero's journey
type story which not every story is a
hero's journey type story but if you're
writing that that book really goes into
kind of what the the structural points
tend to be in those kind of stories and
but yeah I do think to a large extent
people are
speaking about the same things like most
people agree that like the end of act 2
of a movie about 3/4 of the way through
there's usually a major defeat crisis
all is lost moment and then there's that
one last kind of chance in the third act
to solve whatever the main kind of
problem of that story was and they might
call it different things but they kind
of are talking about the same thing did
you read any of the William Goldman
books like which lie did I tell or I did
I read adventures in the screen trade I
think I also read which lie did I tell
but those are more about my life as a
screenwriter as opposed to here's how to
do it you know I don't think he was
trying to teach so much as to talk about
what what life can be like doing it
professionally what was your takeaway
from what he talked about in terms of
what life could be like I know he's a
very straight shooter yeah well I mean I
guess I think I read adventures in the
screen trade before I was really working
in the industry as I recall and you know
it was probably a foundational book at
the time for understanding what it's
like in Hollywood as a writer I remember
him saying things like you know it
basically takes me six months and in six
months I'll have a screenplay it'll be a
real screenplay it may not be the
screenplay you want I mean I'll just be
a screenplay that will get made into a
hit movie but it will be a it will be I
can create this product in six months I
remember that's staying with me and of
course the thing people often quote is
that nobody knows anything line which i
think is sometimes misunderstood a
little bit because I don't think he was
saying nobody knows anything about what
tends to work in story or in movies I
think what he was saying is no one can
say for sure what movie's going to be
successful at the box office which to me
are two somewhat different things and so
I mean I think there are people that
know some things about story structure
and character and writing and what what
tends to work better than what tends to
not work as well they're not hard and
fast rules that are a hundred percent
applicable at all times but I do think
there are principles that are good to
understand and follow as in any endeavor
it's not just something that you just
dive in your first time and wing it and
it all goes great usually however it's
true that nobody can say for sure
this idea this script this movie's gonna
definitely sell or not sell be a hit or
not be a hit and that is something that
he talked about a lot that you know it's
not an exact science
what makes a great story Wow that's a
that's a great question that's a very
big broad question what makes a great
story to me where it starts is a really
compelling problem that is going to take
the whole story to be solved that
millions of strangers consuming that
story would be able to identify with
this problem and care that it gets
solved and be really entertained by the
process of watching people try to solve
it so that's kind of a lot of things in
one but to me that's kind of where it
all starts with there's something that
someone's going through in life that
really matters to them and hopefully to
us as the audience it's really important
it's really difficult it's going to take
a lot of effort and active action toward
trying to solve it which isn't going to
work
so it's difficult it's complicated
trying to solve it usually leads to
pushback and complications and things
that don't go as planned
and so that tends to build the sense of
problematic situation so it's growing
and escalating Oh building over the
course of the story and then in the end
there's some kind of resolution that has
taken the audience on a journey and
usually taken certain characters on a
journey where they're not the same as
what they were and therefore it was
meaningful and important in some way
that they went through that how does
someone know their movie idea sucks well
most of us don't know it's hard to know
without getting third party objective
feedback from someone who isn't just
your friend who's gonna try and
encourage you it can help to put it in a
so-called drawer for a couple of months
we don't really have literal drawers
anymore where we put print it out
screenplays but I certainly will write a
draft or even a few drafts until I feel
pretty good about something and then
I'll put it away and work on something
else for you know two or three months
and then when I come back to it I have a
much better objective sense of what
works and doesn't work then I had when I
was finishing that draft so getting that
objectivity that perspective that's
outside the perspective of the writer
who's just trying to make
work but the evaluator who's just seeing
it for the first time and finding fault
with it is hard to do and it can help to
have those sort of built-in delays
between you writing it and then you
looking at it again and of course other
people can give you that perspective as
well but you know all you can really do
is say well here are the principles of
what makes something good and here's
what I think is good and here's what I'm
trying to do that I think is good and
here's me doing it to the best of my
ability but I think you always end up
with something that you're like people
may all think this sucks I may not have
anybody that likes this or at least the
right people aren't gonna like this
that's always very possible and I
certainly go through that with
everything I've ever written things that
people loved and things that people
didn't love I had that same insecurity
and I remember feeling feeling
encouraged when I read I think it was
John Steinbeck like some journal entry
like before I want to say before Grapes
of Wrath where he was so insecure about
what he was writing it's not gonna live
up to the success he had on some other
thing and he would talk about what he
was writing about and why it just wasn't
working and no one's gonna like it and
so it's kind of like a built-in
insecurity that you have I mean maybe
some people don't have it maybe some
people think everything they write is
great but in my experience the people
that are the that do the best usually
have a pretty highly developed
self-critical Sensibility maybe to their
detriment maybe it goes too far to where
you don't trust in any of your stuff
being a value so but but you can go too
far in either direction you don't really
know if it sucks you just suspect it
might suck or you're worried people are
gonna say that it does so in the end
like all you can really do is learn the
principles you know learn and study to
understand what makes things work and
then try to please yourself try to write
something you would really want to see
so that something that fulfills the
things that you most love and then get
that objective perspective however you
can and and and then hope for the best
cuz you never really know you know what
other people are gonna say if that's
where I was going with that and then you
you you said it before I was even able
to
go there and that is do you find most
writers or the of the camp that they
they're so critical of their own work or
are they of the equally detrimental camp
which is everything they do is amazing
and the world's just waiting for that
can be just as damaging yeah more
damaging I think yeah well yes yeah yeah
I think I think most writers who've been
doing it for a while
tend to be more in the camp of wow this
is hard and I like what I'm writing sort
of for a while but I'm nervous that
people aren't gonna like it and I and I
may be very self-critical I think when
you're first starting out and you write
your first couple of things and no one's
bashed your head and yet with negative
feedback you tend to be more naive and
be more like oh this is fun and this is
good what I've written hey everybody
look at what I wrote and then when you
get actual like aggressively negative
professional level objective feedback
it's like I'm here the first time I got
that I was still living in Ohio where I
grew up and I've written like one
screenplay in college you know I was a
film production major and I was like
wrote my second one and I knew somebody
who knew somebody who was a major
Hollywood producer and they were willing
to send my script to that producer and
after many months the script got sent
back to me
with coverage that that producers reader
had written like a two-page coverage
where they tore my script apart so
violently about how just terrible it was
that it was really shocking and and
obviously demoralizing for a while and
that was my first taste of you can write
something that you think is really good
and and when you send to the people that
really quote matter that could help move
it forward they're not going to give you
any of the benefit the doubt that your
friends are going to give you they're
really looking out like a business is
this product a worthy product that I'm
going to put money and time behind or
not and they're if they don't think so
they're gonna be or if they have to tell
their boss whether it is or not they're
gonna be pretty you know pretty clear
and about why it isn't and most the time
they think it isn't and most the time
those scripts aren't something that this
big producer so
speak would actually be able to do
something with that's just the reality
of the world
so once you've been been beaten down a
little bit by having that happen a few
times I think you tend to be more
self-critical and and obviously I can go
too far to where you're then too down on
yourself or too unsure not confident
enough in what you're doing and also to
you could be you could come off some hit
and there's people waiting in the wings
critics well-established critics that
are just looking for blood in the water
sort I mean that's a real you know
unfortunate part of the industry there
are people just waiting for the next hit
of somebody to have an opinion and then
they're able to promote their piece
based on you know their dislike of
something that the public loves and
having to face the ramifications of that
we know many careers that have probably
been halted for a little while off of
that yeah I mean what it could also
happen is if you've been told you're the
greatest for long enough you can feel
that it's - that it's really easy to
write something that will be successful
maybe you're already very successful and
some other related part of filmmaking
and and now you're writing and then you
know and no one is telling you no you
know and so you can you can having too
much encouragement I mean it's like a
double-edge thing it's like you want
encouragement helpful because most of us
really thrive on and need some but at
the same time if all you get is
encouragement that's not really honest
encouragement it can obviously make you
unaware of you know some of the flaws of
what you're doing or you know keep you
from being as as critical or have as
much you know objective perspective on
your work is it might need yeah the
golden child syndrome yeah I mean no no
no if that's a real designation but yeah
that would be equally viable we know a
lot of people whose downfall has been
from that as well yeah yeah so is there
a happy medium is it can you be do you
think that just takes time so wherever
the pendulum has swung and you fall
under that after you've kind of been
beaten down a little bit that's where
the real magic happens is after you kind
of take a real stock of yourself and
your work
or do some people never self-correct
some people just go into a hole to me
it's more like with so many things it's
like a daily challenge it's a daily
challenge to have the right mindset and
the right attitude toward what you're
doing it's not a thing that you arrive
at suddenly a perfect place where you're
emotionally healthy and you know how to
like view your work in the most sort of
you know critical enough but not too
critical kind of way I think it's more
just like everyday there's a tendency to
hate what you wrote that day or to think
what you wrote that day is genius right
and so it's just a constant practice of
being kind of almost a Zen about it not
what the highs get to higher the lows
get to low not be too down yourself or
too in love with everything you've ever
done either but just be kind of like I'm
just it's like a practice like a
spiritual practice I'm practicing it
writing I'm writing every day and a big
part of writing is practicing the
consciousness that works the best to be
writing and producing stuff that you
feel you know decent about and that
consciousness is kind of like letting go
of opinions even your own opinion to
some extent at a certain point and
letting go of ego and just be trying to
like invite and allow ideas and explore
ideas and a kind of a playful way
knowing that there will be time later
for the critical mind to come in and
hash through all of it but that critical
mind can really strangle the creative
process when what you need most the time
is more ideas not more criticism so but
for me that's a daily challenge to not
get too critical or you know and or not
get too overly confident to the point of
you know not putting something through
the rigors of the creative process of
rewriting and so forth but to just be
like present in the creative ideas state
and then critical wanting to be critical
but not too critical I don't feel like
I'll ever get to a place where I've got
that also handled and I'm just great at
that it's like I have to work at it
daily what is meaningful conflict and
why do so many screenwriters get this
wrong
so meaningful conflict I mean conflict
to me is synonymous with problem so I
remember early in my screenwriting
endeavors I had people sometimes say
your script doesn't have enough conflict
and I was like I understand what that
means like I thought conflict just meant
people fighting and arguing you know or
beating up on each other but then I came
to understand that conflict and problem
mean the same thing so in any story the
audience is most interested and engaged
when there's some kind of problem that
someone is actively trying to resolve
that's pretty much like scene writing
101 story 101 you always want to be
focused on that and whenever there isn't
a problem to be solved or whenever no
one's trying to solve it even if it
exists audience engagement and motional
engagement tends to sag a little bit so
meaningful conflict would just mean
conflict that is really related to the
overall goal of the story you know every
story kind of begins with something that
makes us go oh here's what needs to be
solved here's the outcome that's being
pursued that hopefully I'm emotionally
invested I want to see them reach that
outcome so meaningful conflict would be
conflict in scenes then which have to do
with that outcome and and how is it
going trying to get to that outcome
because you could have conflict that
doesn't really relate to the larger
story goal that wouldn't be so
meaningful it would just be conflict for
the sake of conflict so ideally it's
conflict that matters to the story and
you might also have like a B story like
there's a conflicted relationship with
somebody who the ally or the love
interest or something and so you might
have meaningful convict it's advancing
the B story doesn't always have to be
about whatever that kind of a story goal
is but to me the most important thing is
you do need constant conflict which
means constant problems and it should be
meaningful to whatever we're all there
to try to see work out what about when
people put too much conflict right away
I'm not thinking of let's say I know
it's really dating myself with the movie
staying alive it was great to see it's
such a great fellow I just have to go
when John Travolta's characters what
sort of strutting down the street and
he's like he bumps into Sylvester
Stallone's character and it kind of
shows like okay this is New York City
and it's very like
and you're up against all these people
it's a little bit contentious but it
works because it kind of shows that but
then sometimes I've seen films where
there's just - there's like an argument
that doesn't belong in there that's
right away how do you balance my feeling
about the beginning of a movie is that
you're mostly trying to get the audience
to understand the main character and
their status quo life and emotionally
get invested in who they are and what
their basic life situation is before the
big problem has emerged which will then
occupy the rest of the story
that big problem tends to emerge as the
catalyst or the inciting event or
inciting incident you know maybe about
12 pages in if you use like the save the
cat page count once that thing happens
that rocks their world and then set them
on a mission ultimately for the rest of
the story to resolve whatever happened
at that catalyst part of the catalyst
you're just introducing the audience to
the main character and their world and
your hopefully getting them
understanding enough about that
character that they can start to feel
they know them and they know their
situation writers often have issues with
this where they don't really do that
very well they don't stay with the main
character and take the time to kind of
illustrate what their current life is
and make them emotionally accessible to
the audience and make us have a reason
to want to follow them that that term
save the cat the idea if they save a cat
in the first 10 pages will care about
them is kind of a half joking but but
the idea that we we get invested in the
character for some reason that the
audience is led to by the writer give us
a reason to care because we tend to not
care about some stranger in a movie
unless you make us care so that's like
almost the writers first and foremost
job make us care and so it starts the
beginning so to me the opening scenes of
a movie the first 10 pages or so they
should have conflict in them because
every scene should have conflict but
that conflict should be just the normal
conflicts of that characters everyday
life kind of up until before the
catalyst hits even a move even a movie
like Saving Private Ryan which opens
with the most biggest conflict you could
imagine you know storming Omaha Beach
ultimately that's just illustrating what
Tom Hanks his life was right before the
catalyst of the
movie the catalyst being he gets the
order that you've got to go save Private
Ryan right that sets in motion the real
story problem for the rest of the movie
in the outcome that we all get invested
in prior to that we're just seeing well
what's captain Miller's life in his
unit's life like before they get that
order how do we get up to speed with who
he is and what he's dealing with and
what's going on in his life right now
he's got a very special version of that
but that's kind of the same thing for
everyone's for every movie so you can
have conflict you should have conflict
but sometimes people want to open with
something really big where they're
already launching the story on page one
in other words like the catalyst event
is happening at the very beginning
before we have any idea who is who or
what the world of the story is and I
think that tends to be a mistake because
the audience needs some time to get up
to speed and invested first or I didn't
even like let's say big little lies you
have Reese Witherspoon and it's a very
you know sort of manicured you know it
seems more pampered life but there's
these little dilemmas throughout like
with the carpool and going to the school
and someone's in her way and she's not
getting what she wants from her child
and so used you see these little mini
conflicts being set up even though it
doesn't seem like the same as a war
scene yeah conflicts but not the one big
conflict that's gonna drive the rest of
the the story from that point forward
and in a series like that you're also
doing that times for different
characters I think where each one of
those characters gets some of those
scenes in the beginning that makes us go
okay here's this person here's their
life situation here's the basic
conflicts for them here's their basic
personality their basic desires and
what's in the way of those desires
nothing huge has happened to rock their
world and start the story but I get who
they are I get who Nicole Kidman is I
get who shailene woodley is etc so yeah
and if that's part of why writing a
pilot can be harder because you have to
set up multiple characters and you have
to do it quickly so you have to find the
right way to make the audience go I get
who they are and I kind of am intrigued
and I kind of care about them a little I
want to see where life is going for them
where is it a movie you usually only
have one main character and you've got
like 10 12 pages to just do it for them
you don't have to do it for anybody
in fact you shouldn't be trying to spend
time on scenes about other characters
and the first 10 pages in my view
because the whole goal is to get us
caring about the main character because
we're gonna subjectively experience the
rest of the story through their point of
view so it's not about showing us these
other people what's going on with them
it's about get us inside their world and
their psychology looking out through
their eyes as they live their life
we're and so was staying alive going
back to a John Travolta checks in any
messages and he's in this sort of like
getting a weekly motel or whatever that
in New York City where he's a struggling
actor dancer and of course the guy is
like no so it just shows again this guy
is okay another weak humble and sort of
broke and you that kind of sets off his
world because that's basically before he
meets the Finola Hughes character yeah
it's this is my normal life and here are
the problems in my normal life that are
just the status quo situation that and
it makes you care about him because he's
got this kind of undeserved misfortune
you always feel for the underdog the
person that wants something they can't
have it they're working toward but
nobody cares so that's a classic way to
make a audience want to invest in the
main character and those opening pages
we have a question here from Milly
purpose podcast and they asked what do
you think made your work stand out that
won awards did you do something
different or would you consider it luck
well my work that won awards I assume
they're talking about like the Emmy
Awards for Saving Private Ryan in bandit
I'm sorry not Stephen Fry Ryan bandit
brothers and from the earths of the Moon
and it wasn't that those were my work
and it won awards just because of my
work right those were big team efforts
and those were projects you know
produced by you know Tom Hanks and and
based on books written by people like
Stephen Ambrose and they were true
stories and you know HBO put a lot of
money into them so it wasn't so much it
won awards because of what little Eric
Bork did but I played a role in this
group of writers and producers on both
of them and so I wouldn't say I made it
win awards I just contributed to
something that as a whole won awards so
and was it luck I mean
you know I was lucky to be Tom Hanks
assistant I was lucky that he read some
of my stuff and wanted to promote me and
give me this opportunity I was lucky
that a producer came on board that
mentored me and helped me find my voice
and a way to write scripts for these
things that people would think would
work I was lucky that HBO put all this
money into I mean there's a lot of luck
along the way and then there's the
preparation you know that hopefully
you're you're prepared and and you've
got the ability to do what's needed and
but a lot of it was me learning on the
fly and trying to kind of do my best
feeling overmatched by all of it but
then eventually finding my way around
okay here's how you do this you know and
I'm doing doing a decent job and because
we're playing my part in it so I don't
know that it's that I did something very
special or different or unique that I
could put my finger on exactly but
obviously somehow there was a fit there
where I was able to contribute something
and be part of these amazingly well you
know loved big projects and you put in a
lot of time doing jobs that maybe some
people wouldn't take I know we talked
about that in our last interview before
today just you know just you did temping
and things like that and some people
might not want to do that right away and
there's a delusion that well I I don't
do that you know and those jobs are
actually very difficult they're very
difficult to show up every day to some
of those was it's very stressful and you
know you're sort of a low person on the
totem pole or whatever but so doing time
sort of doing that and cultivating
relationships and a trust factor yeah
yeah that's true I mean I I was also
doing my time obviously writing and
trying to learn the craft and you know
generating material and getting feedback
and all that but yeah for me getting a
job at the temp was something that I
like moved to LA to do so it wasn't like
I'm above that it was more like oh this
is a way you can like get in the
industry and sort of learn and get
closer to all of it and eventually have
an easier chance at maybe making the
right contacts etc and also getting
better at it because you're around it so
but it can be hard to take this kind of
job especially if you know you're
your 40s and have kids or something and
on a mortgage and Iowa you know so those
are usually jobs taken by people in
their 20s sort of right out of college
like I was who are living in LA are
willing to able to move to LA and that
certainly can be helpful so I took it
more as a very helpful way to move
forward but yeah at the time low paying
and sometimes difficult bosses but for
the most part I found it a better place
to work than you know the Blockbuster
Video I managed in Dayton Ohio or the
you know you know restaurants I was
waiting tables that before that I'm
hoping we can talk about the Quentin
Tarantino film Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood I know you just wrote a blog
post it's flying wrestler yes Colin yes
okay and spoiler alert for anyone tuning
in from the problem perspective what are
some of the biggest problems these is it
really characters I mean is there really
one protagonist in the film I should ask
first
probably well my take on it on once the
time in Hollywood is that there it's set
up like there are three stories three
characters that were following right
three stars of the movie and I didn't
really feel that Margot Robbie had a
story per se because she didn't really
have a problem so there was not not
really a problem for her to try to
address it was more just we're meeting
her and we're seeing what she's like and
we're seeing her being kind of a giddy
you know young actress watching a movie
that she's in and how she's excited so
we establish her as a sympathetic
character so it's not like she really
has a story per se she's just a presence
in the movie who gets some of her own
scenes which is somewhat unusual but she
doesn't take up a huge chunk of the
movie then you have two other characters
who each have a problem in their lives I
would say you know Leonardo DiCaprio's
character feels like his acting career
is sort of you know on the wane and Brad
Pitt is you know not really working as a
stuntman anymore and doesn't kind of
like have the life he really wants
either so they're both set up in a way
that that they have kind of a problem in
their life a generalized problem like
you normally have at the beginning of a
movie what they don't really have is the
more
traditional kind of catalyst that rocks
their world like one big event happens
where it's like now I've got a
particular goal or a particular mission
amount to try to solve this big problem
that's gonna take the whole movie to
solve it doesn't really work in that
traditional way because I would say
Leo's problem he's not trying to solve
it he's more just kind of stuck in it
and he gets this job acting on a TV show
and he's not necessarily that excited
about he's not using that try to like
fix something in his acting career he's
just doing it because he's got this gig
to do same thing with Brad Pitt he's
kind of hanging out and doing what his
current job is and living his current
life so to me it's a more
non-traditional kind of day in the life
slice of life type of movie and in a way
where we spend I think it's like two
full days in their lives and then
another day that happens months later at
the end where we're not we're not seeing
characters actively trying to fix some
life problem that's urgent it's more
that they kind of have well for Brad and
leo they kind of have problems but
they're not out there how do I fix my
problem so to speak then the end of the
movie gives us an interesting unexpected
kind of sense of resolution that happens
but it kind of happens where we feel
like we owe is life is going to take a
positive turn maybe because of
everything that happened and but it kind
of comes more through the back door it's
not the usual he's trying to do
something and it's building to a climax
it's more that he's just kind of like
living his life and and it's told in a
way that some people are describing is
meandering so that the pace is not the
normal Hollywood movie pace so there's
the movies really stay with me and
there's a lot that I like about it and I
find myself like reading about it and so
forth so it was more just I wanted to
point out what I think are at the heart
of what some people aren't loving about
it which is a sense of maybe a slow pace
or a sense of what this movie really
about it doesn't have the normal kind of
story and I wasn't prepared for the
length or for that pace when I went in
based on the trailers and so forth so I
was kind of like oh this is really not
the normal
kind of storytelling that we're used to
and it's not really a story in the
normal way it's more like three
characters with a certain life situation
and we're just living life with them for
a couple of days what if the protagonist
was actually Hollywood and the industry
and the reason that there's no
particular one problem is that it shows
the different levels of problems and the
contrast so you have Brad Pitt's
character who seems pretty satisfied
with his life even though by most
people's definition it would not be
success
whereas Leonardo DiCaprio is a trick
Dalton his would actually be I mean he's
in his pool like rehearsing lines for a
film so I you know and but that's kind
of how this town like you see a lot of
people that seem like they're very
unsatisfied but they actually have
achieved so much so that's really the
problem it's just sort of the viewpoint
of the industry maybe I'm getting too
well I mean movies work on a number of
different levels and I and I think that
it does do that it's exploring life in
Hollywood during a certain period of
time life in Los Angeles during a
changing time in our society and it does
it in ways that I think are really
interesting I would just say that
Hollywood can't be a protagonist you
know like a place isn't a protagonist
than the way I would just define it or a
main character because to me a main
character or a protagonist is a person
typically who's got something they're
trying to solve they're a sentient being
who's got an issue that we can all
relate to that they're out there in life
trying to fix that issue so obviously
Hollywood isn't doing that so they can't
really stand in for a main character
Hollywood can't as a whole but you know
he may have been well aware that he was
doing it this way on purpose and that it
wasn't traditional and that's okay and
it is okay it's making a lot of money
it's getting great reviews it's going to
win awards there's just maybe some
people that walk out going on I didn't
like as much as I thought I would which
happens with pretty much every movie so
but as somebody who's like kind of
teaching screenwriting and analyzing why
I like and don't like different things
you know I tend to sit down at the blog
ago well here's my take on it and here's
why I thought it could've been short
so one would figure that a story about
the entertainment industry would be
inherent with conflict you'd almost have
to take parts of conflict out but you
felt possibly that the movie Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood did not have enough
conflict it's not that it didn't have
enough conflict it did have conflict in
it I would say Margot Robbie's slice of
the story didn't have any conflict in it
but that's a very small slice I would
say that it's more that characters
aren't actively pursuing resolution to a
pressing problem or desire that they're
focused on that's building and
escalating over the course of the film
but there is conflict also the scenes
are tended to be very long longer than
we're used to and they may feel like
nothing's really happening regarding the
conflict or the problem for a quite
quite a long time like you know Leo is
on the set and he sits down next to this
child actress and they have actor and
they have this conversation that doesn't
feel like it's necessarily like it's
taking a taking a while but it's
well-written and it's engaging in its
own way it's just not the typical length
and pacing that we're used to which some
people might find very refreshing I know
that they do but others might be like
where's this going why are we just
sitting here on this kind of mundane
conversation but eventually it leads
somewhere which is he wants to impress
this little girl actor and then we have
the scene that he does with her which is
also a very long scene in a movie in
other words they take much more time
than you would normally see to show that
he puts on a good performance and
impresses her and feels good about it
they don't do it as quickly as movies
typically do in today's Hollywood or
even in 1969 Hollywood although the
pacing then was definitely slower than
it is now and who knows if that was one
of his thoughts that I'm going to a kind
of pacing that's more of a bygone era
I'm not sure and with the Sharon Tate
character played by Margot Robbie if
people are aware of Sharon Tate's story
maybe is there some magic in showing
this like amazing dreamlike life you
know beautiful woman seems sweet
but then if you go back and you research
you realize that is very tragic up into
that you know point yeah I think you're
right I think that and some people point
that out in comments on the blog post I
did which I think they're they're right
in saying the audience if they know what
happened with the Manson murders there's
an inherent tension waiting to see
what's gonna happen with the Manson
murders and even though none of our main
characters are actively trying to do
anything to solve anything other than
the one very compelling scene where Brad
Pitt is at spawn ranch the rest of the
time they're kind of oblivious to are
not focused on that and and so yeah it
puts this character in jeopardy
we know what had she rented is facing so
yeah I think that is kind of their way
of giving you a story that has a
resolution at the end it just doesn't
have the typical thing of characters or
trying to solve it over the course of
the middle they're just kind of living
there live in the end put in a situation
where something really huge happens
that's that that ends up creating a
resolution but one thing I think I noted
also in my post is that the Tarantino
movies I know usually have
life-and-death stakes pretty much
constantly underlying almost every scene
like Pulp Fiction inglorious basterds
Reservoir Dogs and so those scenes in
those movies also tend to be quite long
like the opening scene inglourious
basterds which is this really great
scene but it's got life-and-death
tension at every moment so we're on the
edge of our seats going at some point
this is good a turn and someone's gonna
get killed when you don't have that
tension I think it's harder to get away
with longer scenes although he seems to
be getting away with it with with it we
had a lot of ways with this movie is
doing very well and I'm not trying to to
completely slam it but as I analyze my
own reaction and some other people
saying it feels meandering and so forth
plotless in a way I think that's kind of
what they're referring to in the 40 year
old virgin Steve Carell's character
seems to have a clearly defined problem
but is that really what the problem is
like did the audience goes in with one
vision of what his problem is but is
that really his real
in the end well I mean he a lot of times
you have an external problem in a kind
of an internal arc as well and those two
things are intertwined and so they both
kind of get resolved in the end so for
me his external problem is that he's a
40 year old virgin and these people at
work know about it now and are focused
on it and he's terrified and
self-conscious and feels overwhelmed and
over in over his head and and nothing
goes right as he's trying to deal with
now I have this woman I'm dating and
these people he's they're trying to get
me you know having sex with and so forth
and so I do think the external problem
for the whole movie is is he gonna be
resolved to be able to resolve his
virginity and do it in a way that he's
happy with which probably means this
woman he's in relationship with is gonna
know and it's gonna be okay and they're
gonna finally have sex and it's all
gonna be fine
so that's the external problem so I
don't think it really changes in terms
of that being the problem that we spend
the whole movie waiting to see resolved
internally he's got his own art about
his own self image and his own idea of
who he is and his own you know
willingness to grow and change as an
adult man which is intertwined with that
so he's got all the action figures in
their boxes and he doesn't drive he
rides a bicycle and you know there's all
these things that are kind of like
childlike about him as well and and so
you kind of see at a certain point that
he has to internally change in some way
in order to have the external thing work
out so the way he gets internally he
gets pressured to change in the big
blowup scene with her which is really
about his secret that he hasn't told her
but they're selling all of his stuff
he's freaking out about it right because
she wants him to sell on eBay all of his
toys so he can like open his own store
and like be a grown-up kind of and he
and he's not ready to do that so on some
level he's not ready to be a grown-up so
there's that internal arc but the
external problem is losing his virginity
successfully and being able to be with
her okay so it seems like that's very
clear to the audience the internal and
external conflict with once upon a time
Hollywood do you feel that the internal
and external are clear or there's just
more of an external and there wasn't so
much of an internal with Leo's character
if he is the main let's say well you
realize just three protagonists I mean I
think there's I think there are external
internal arcs for we'll just talk about
Leo's character it's just that he's not
actively pursuing a resolution in a way
that's really super stressful the way it
is in the 40 year old virgin and it and
it plays out in a slower paced way but
base guy would say his external problem
is his acting career seems to be waning
and he doesn't know what to do and he
feels like he has no way to fix it then
there's like this one lengthy sequence
in the middle where he's acting on this
TV show and he gets inspired to do a
good job that day and he does after some
conflict along the way and then in the
end what happens with the whole Manson
stuff he has another opportunity to do
something that in the end feels like it
kind of in a weird way it works out and
helps him meet the next-door neighbors
and get an entree into the new Hollywood
world that Sharon Tate and Roman
Polanski represent that he was felt shut
out of before so you do see a resolution
to that problem in a way and you also
have there's a sequence where time has
passed where he's like gone to Italy and
stuff right and so there's some sense
that maybe he's resolving that too by
going and doing those I guess spaghetti
westerns and stuff so but the the
internal arc is I think it's more faint
but it's basically I think it's just
kind of like he feels kind of like sorry
for himself and he has to just kind of
like buck up and you know be about the
work instead of his own you know career
prospects and for Brad Pitt I think
there's less there's less going on I
mean he's not really he not only is he
not pursuing a resolution we don't
necessarily feel like Oh his stuntman
career is falling apart and it matters
it's just kind of like okay he's he's
now at a certain point he's not gonna be
other payroll anymore with Leo and it's
like oh that's sad but that doesn't kind
of happen till right near the end so I
think there's it's more a sense of heat
like you said he's kind of happy living
his life it seems like even though he
doesn't have a lot so unlike we
he's not even bothered by his problem so
why would the audience we're not really
bothered we're just kind of like
enjoying watching the guy and I think
there's some great scenes like the one
where he goes to spawn ranch I think is
a really compelling sequence but there's
not that sort of overall problem that
were really urgently addressing and he's
actively kind of chasing throughout the
movie but maybe is that that characters
problem the fact that sorry cliff booths
problem is that he is too content with
this like mediocrity and being in this
trailer and he's got this adorable dog
and they're kind of like you know he's
eating what these TV dinners or whatever
his macaroni and cheese and it's almost
like he's not okay it's because he's not
shaken up by that like how the he's too
complacent I don't think we see him as
too complacent I think we just see him
as a guy that's kind of fine with his
life and I don't think we're saying oh
you need to fix your life you need to
change and find some new path toward
being a stuntman or whatever nor do I
think he really finds one in the end I
mean he also has this climactic sequence
on that fateful day in August and maybe
his life will be somewhat different
after that I can't remember if there's a
sense that he's going to keep working
for Leo after all or but I don't think
there I don't think there's really a
sense of a problem it's like he tries to
get hired on that one job and they're
not gonna hire him and then we have the
flashback to when he made those people
mad which is why they don't want him to
work but it's a very light problem it's
the kind of problem you'd normally see
in the first few pages of a script which
is oh he's a stunt man he's not really
working as a stunt man and he wishes he
was and then usually there'd be some big
catalyst of oh this big thing happens
and now he's gonna spend the rest of the
movie trying to solve this big thing we
don't really have that big thing until
the very end he has a big thing but he
solved that so kind of easily that I
don't think there's a ton of tension and
concern about it because he's clearly
just mr. super badass so you know it's
it's fun to watch it away it's certainly
riveting but it's not a character who's
like growing and changing and solving
some inner or outer problem in his life
I didn't think
whereas with the 40 year old version
steve carell there is this arc yeah he's
solving a very important problem that's
plaguing his life at the end of that
movie he's completely changed at the end
he's a grown-up now
what is a scriptment so a scriptment is
kind of a word for something that's
somewhere between a script and a
treatment where that some writers like
to use that I kind of recommended a blog
at one point that people consider which
is a document where traditionally an
outline or a treatment which are
sometimes used to mean the same thing is
a scene-by-scene description of
everything that happens in a script it
doesn't have dialogue yet it doesn't
have the actual interior movie studio
offices day so and so is sig minor
doesn't have all that it's just saying
in this scene you know the hero talks to
the studio chief and they fight about
his salary on the movie or whatever so
you're describing the basic content
basic conflict of a scene in a treatment
or an outline whereas a script obviously
you're scripting it all out so the idea
of a script mint is a in-between
document that's sort of longer than a
treatment or outline but shorter than a
script where you go a bit further to
figure out the details of what happens
in the scene maybe you even have some
snippets of dialogue but what I found is
when I have an outline where you know in
this scene you know these two people
have this conflict about whatever and I
feel like that works in the outline and
then I go to sit down and write that
scene the script what I'm usually faced
with is oh I don't know nearly enough
yet to write that scene I don't know
enough about what should or could happen
in that scene I have a lot more work to
do to kind of figure out how this all
plays out in that scene and so that work
that happens in between becomes once
I've done that work I'm sort of like I'm
expanding my outline into something that
you know more like you would call like a
script meant because there's that extra
step of work required to be able to
write the scene so then don't do the
scriptment after you've written the
script because I could see some people
doing it in Reverse after their first
draft yeah there's no point in doing a
scriptment after you've written the
script it's only purpose is to expand
your treatment or outline with more
depth and specificity so it's easier to
write the scenes in the actual script
once you start doing that because the
typical outline is a little too bereft
of those details and specificity for you
to be able to easily write the scene
there's this interim process of needing
to kind of know more and figure out more
before the scenes just gonna easily flow
in my experience so then you wouldn't
use it as a measure to see if let's
suppose you go through your first draft
and say this isn't working I need to do
sort of a more macro view of it but I
don't want to totally change everything
around wouldn't that be another way
where you could do more of a macro view
of it well yes that that is important
when you're when you're something isn't
working in the script a lot of times
it's a bigger problem that you can't
just be solved by changing stuff in the
scripts you have to take a step back to
a prior stage like a script man or an
outline or whatever to sort of figure
out what's not working story wise
because you can't see it in the scenes
that are written in the script maybe you
just kind of sense it this happens
constantly and you have to go well
what's really not working here do I need
to rethink this movie do I have to re
outline the second act we have to come
up with some new different scenes
because it's not working how I thought
it would and so then you go back to
outline scriptment
whatever and then eventually come back
to the script once you figure out the
new changes that you decided that you
needed
what mistakes two writers make writing
characters I think that the challenge
with characters that that I have even is
creating three-dimensional people that
feel real and interesting to the
audience and compelling and intriguing
and sympathetic and all the things that
you want them to be so it's not so much
that you're writing the character
because you're like writing the script
that has the character in it prior to
writing the script you're like figuring
out who the character is and what you're
going to present about that character to
the audience and I think it's kind of
harder than it looks to come up with a
character that feels real it feels like
they're really coming from real life
somehow and is really interesting and
that audiences will care enough about
them and want to follow them because
they're going to relate to them on some
level so it's like figuring out what are
the key aspects of that character that
define them for this movie or this TV
Cirie's what are the problems that
they're mainly dealing with what are
their internal issues their main and
trial issue and their main external
problem and then trying to write in such
a way that they're not just a tool of
the story or the concept but that they
actually feel like you know the audience
gets drawn into the reality their life
it feels super real somehow the way that
the character is drawn it's not easy to
do that but that's the best characters
you feel like this is a real
flesh-and-blood human being and it has
to do with they're not just a stereotype
they have elements they might start with
one aspect that could be a cliche or a
stereotype or a trope or a one
dimensional feature but then they have
something else going on that maybe is
surprising and very different I've read
an article online recently I think it
was on script reader probes website
where they talked about lengthy
character bios aren't really that
helpful it's better to think of your
characters in terms of one main quality
that most people would define them as
and then one surprising kind of twist
that you wouldn't expect so they use the
example of American Beauty and they
talked about like this one character
West Bentleys character is a wise beyond
his years
character like that's his main quality
but he's also a drug dealer which is
like a weird thing that you maybe
wouldn't expect and each of the like
main cares of that movie they defined in
that way the you know mena Suvari s
character is this like flirty you know
teen but in reality she's an insecure
version and so like there's these
surprising things that just this quality
with this opposite or different quality
but finding that first quality even is
important because it's easy to just kind
of be vague about who these people are
you want to think in terms of if a
stranger which is what your audience is
we're a look at this character in their
life what would be the one word
description they'd have of the type of
person that is not what they look like
but the type of person that they are
what's the main quality that comes
through and sort of figuring out what
that quality is and then finding a way
to subvert it to make them more
dimensional
seems like a good thing something I've
been playing with lately and even let's
say Good Will Hunting I mean the fact
that Matt Damon is supposedly this
janitor that can just solve this
unbelievable math equation just seems
like oh that's never gonna work but then
when you watch him against these all
these other characters he seems like a
real guy like I mean like that that
person exists to me you see what I'm
saying
but he's also a good example of these
two opposing qualities one quality being
that he's this kind of sort of like
working-class tough guy
janitor Street kid who's got a chip on
his shoulder who happens to be a
brilliant genius like two things you
wouldn't think go together
what's your process for approaching
dialog you know it's kind of instinctual
I think once I know what's happening in
the scene and I know where it's going
like what where the characters enter the
scene it's all about whose scene is it
what are they trying to achieve in that
scene what's in the way and sort of what
are they doing to try to get through
whatever's in the way that's pretty much
the template for pretty much every scene
so then it's like okay part of that is
gonna be dialogue part of that is gonna
be what they say and what they say
should be the the things that they would
believably say given who they are and
what their unique voice and way of
speaking is in that situation given
what's going on and what they want so
you want to avoid the mistake that
people often make with expositional
dialogue where people just speak
information that the audience needs to
know but they really wouldn't say in
that moment you want them to be saying
the things that they would really say
when I'm doing it it's kind of
instinctual and I'm just sort of quickly
writing what I have people say and then
maybe go back and revise it but what's
probably in the back of my mind is it
needs to be what they would naturally
say given who they are and what they
want and people also don't always just
express everything they want right the
best dialogue has subtext which means
the audience can pick up that they're
thinking and feeling something they're
not saying but what they're saying is
what they think is the right thing to
say to try to like get whatever it is
that they want or the only thing that
they're sort of able to say for whatever
reason given who they are and what's
going on but it's helpful if there's
this sense of subtext of we know what
the inner life is underneath that that
they're not saying but what they are
saying is hopefully feels real for that
character and hopefully is entertaining
and keeping with whatever the genre is I
mean it's a comedy obviously your
dialogue is going to often be trying to
be funny as well so yeah it's not so
much of figuring it out as it is just
instinctually moving through it with
those kind of things in the back of my
mind and then of course tons of revising
going back and rewriting and revising
you know compressing you know cutting
editing the dialogue over time well
there's certain scenes that stand out
that are great for subtext it's a great
study in that well there I mean Robert
McKee in his book story analyzed the
scene in Casablanca with Humphrey Bogart
and Ingrid Bergman where he he gives you
on the page all the dialogue in the
scene and then he explains to you what
the subtext is so that's a great that's
like the thing that stayed with me the
most from that book it was a really
helpful thing there's that scene in
Annie Hall the famous scene where Alby
is at Annie's apartment and he's looking
around it like the photos on the wall
and he's saying stuff but then in
subtitles they tell you the subtext
which is like you're a really attractive
girl but what he's saying is that's an
interesting use of negative space and
her subject is I hope he's not a jerk
like the others but what she's saying is
oh really you think so so I mean it's a
comedic you know thing but it's kind of
showing you what subtext is I think
Humphrey Bogart was sort of the master
at subtext because so much of his stuff
is like sarcasm and sort of but that
there is like without saying much
there's a look there's a there's a jab
and a lot of things he's a good question
I don't know I mean I don't know how
much credit to give actors for it
because really it's in the writing to
some extent you need the you need the
scenes and the characters to be to have
that inner life that's gonna be clear
the audience but also have dialogue on
the page that is not exactly what
they're thinking and feeling you know
where you can feel the gap at the same
time it's a big part of acting I think
is to know what am I really feeling and
thinking because I'm not saying it and
what am I saying and how I portray what
I'm really thinking and feeling to the
audience even though I'm sort of hiding
it in a way in my dialogue where I'm not
quite coming out with it in my dialogue
for whatever reason and obviously there
are great actors who who do that
particularly well do you think certain
decades of cinema have more or less
subtext I don't know about that I would
say that television writing
traditionally has intended to have less
subtext especially kind of like what we
really think of as like prime
Time Network dramas and comedies usually
have a lot of dialogue and the dialogue
tends to be a little more on the surface
with just saying whatever it is people
are thinking and feeling although
nowadays when we have all these TV shows
that are more movie like and then have a
different feel to them you might see a
lot of subtext in the dialogue there as
you might do in movies it's a more I
guess slightly more like sophisticated
kind of thing which doesn't isn't
necessarily present in certain genres
like if it's in if it's Bruce Willis in
die hard there's probably not a lot of
subtext right or if it's you know South
Park is not filled with subtext right so
but sort of like serious dramas you know
tend to have more subtext or just you
know I hate to use like a pejorative
that you know it's good if you have it
and bad if you don't but to some extent
that's true that it tends to be more
interesting and involving if we're
seeing people who aren't saying
everything they're really thinking
I mean fleabag I don't you've seen
fleabag on Amazon as a series that I
recently watched both seasons of and it
has this great device where this the
main character turns to the camera and
like kind of tells us sometimes her
subtext and it says it's running
dialogue with the camera which they did
a little bit in house of cards and other
shows have done it too they do it in
their own unique way so that the
audience is in on it she doesn't give us
every bit of subtext but she gives us
some point it looks and moments of
here's what she's really thinking but
she's saying something different and I
mean this in all seriousness you think
of Bruce Willis though in moonlighting
and it was tons of subtext between he
and she's simple right yeah it
depends on the genre it's not about the
actor does or doesn't do it it's about
the project yeah oh so you don't think
that's certain you think certain actors
get more roles in terms of you know cuz
you think of Samuel Jackson's character
and he's so great and everything but
he's just gonna say what he feels you
know and he's gonna be he's gonna have
this moment or he's gonna have like a
little mini meltdown and everyone's
gonna be kind of at his mercy and then
they're gonna kind of like do what they
he wants them to do like certain actors
seem to get it seems like more of one
style and the other I mean they may get
cast in roles that are not on subtext E
roles more I suppose but I don't know
that it's certain actors do subtext and
some don't or some are better
some aren't I think it more as a writing
thing it's more what kind of scene is it
you know because we really talk about
the scene level dialogue is operates on
the scene level so what kind of scene is
it who are the people in the scene and
what are the agendas and what are they
trying to communicate or achieve and
what are they really thinking and
feeling and are those things going to be
in the dialogue or not kind of just
depends on the kind of genre and the
kind of scene it is I think so aaron
sorkin maybe less subtext Gillian Flynn
maybe more with gone girl in different
things yeah that's a good point
aaron sorkin I think is less subtext he
because he tends to write these very you
know smart people articulately laying
out arguments for things I mean I think
of like the West Wing classically that
way and so yeah it's not yeah it's not
subtext ii for the most part it's very
come out and say your opinion and argue
it with somebody it's kind of an
intellectual cerebral type of writing I
think that's engaging on that level it's
entertaining on that level
and I'm not saying that he doesn't ever
have scenes that have subtext I'm sure
he does look if you look at the social
network I could probably imagine scenes
that have a lot of subtext you know
where Justin Timberlake's on the phone
with you know Eduardo and he's saying
one thing but we know what he's really
you mean you know like there's not the
Android never does it or can't do it
it's just the style he's most known for
like from the West Wing I think you're
right is less subtext II
do you outline all of your work every
time I do Allen all my work and I think
most screenwriters do but as with
everything in the writing process
there's no like one definite cookie
cutter method that always works great
all the time
so I'm always aware that every new
project is like a new adventure and a
new kind of chaotic mess of the process
of how it turns into whatever it turns
into and so outlining pre-planning
everything has its obvious pros and cons
the cons are that maybe there's a
spontaneity that's lost or a it could go
in some direction that surprised you if
you just sort of free Road and didn't
know where it was going which I think
novelists tend to do and maybe some
screenwriters do that too but the the
pro of outlining is that you have a
solid story structurally and you kind of
figure it all out in a way that's hard
to do when you're in the middle of
writing scenes you know so but I think
screenwriting tends to require that
structure more because one of the
reasons I think is didn't like novel
writing you can be inside a character's
head and in in screenwriting you're
really describing action the people are
taking what they're physically doing
that we would see and what they're
saying and a lot of the content of the
story is underneath that in a novel you
can just write that other content
because a lot of its like internal
thoughts not every not every novel has a
lot of internal thoughts but many do
whereas in a screenplay you usually
can't really do that so for the audience
to really understand what's going on the
story and what it all means and what
people want and feel you have to
construct it in a way that's sort of
like a Rubik's Cube kind of where if you
don't pre-plan it it's like impossible
to solve it it seems like it's probably
not impossible but that's been my
experience in my training so I outline
and I usually recommend that writers do
but some people work better where they
can just jump into scenes at an earlier
part of the process and maybe they
discover things that then later go into
the outline and there's a back-and-forth
there's no one method that I think you
have to do it this one way so you've
seen that where people do their first
draft and
they may be put in the proverbial drawer
and then they go and they could outline
later to see well it's not that you
outline later it's that you see problems
in the script and then you go back to
the outline stage to try to address
those problems and make it more coherent
I mean there are definitely a lot of
writers who are good at scene writing
but not good at structure and not good
at the kind of architecture of a story
and and so and I have counseled many
writers and with that situation and
sometimes they have a real difficult
time taking a step back to the sort of
structure or they're like macro view of
their story or even their concept where
they're they're more about I'm
comfortable when I'm writing scenes and
I think most writers are more
comfortable writing scenes especially if
you know roughly what the scenes are
supposed to be are gonna be and you can
just write them it can be harder to go
well let me analyze the story from a
larger perspective but the screenwriters
seem to need to be able to do that and
that usually involves some sort of
outlying and pre-planning that you
actually write down before you jump into
the actual script document did you
outline for your book I did outline for
my book yes and so how was that for you
because I know you you you've write a
blog I don't know if your blog came it
definitely it came before the book
obviously so are you taking you know
prior blog posts and plugging them in as
chapters yeah there is some material
from prior blog posts yes where but then
I came up with this sort of
superstructure for the book as a concept
which is that it's going to be these
seven elements and each one has its own
chapter and then I might have had some
material on my blog from years ago that
fit that if I repurposed and revised it
somewhat and then also writing some new
material as well
does every screenwriter need an agent or
a manager you do if you're not gonna
produce your work independently and
you're gonna try and get it sold and get
it get it produced by someone else it's
pretty hard to do it without that unless
you have a very close friend or relative
who's a producer or you know in a
position to kind of Greenland a movie
but for the most part all writers that
work in the industry have an agent
and/or manager although right now
writers have kind of fired their agents
because of big dispute that the Writers
Guild is having with the agencies as a
whole but putting that aside most
successful writers these days have both
some have only one or the other but
those people are your way of getting
your work to the potential buyers it's
really difficult to do that on one's own
[Music]
you know almost impossible really to to
launch a writing career where you never
had an agent or a manager that's being
the person that introduces you to those
people that rely on them to filter out
all of the people that aren't worthy of
their time so to speak in terms of their
work and their writing so you know the
industry relies on those representatives
to some extent to recommend writers and
scripts and projects and pitches to them
and they'll only be interested if
they're it comes to them recommended by
someone they trust just because there's
a volume of stuff out there that it's
hard for them to sift through all of it
the producers the executives etc without
somebody who's sort of performing that
function for them so in a way that's
what agents and managers do they also
help writers figure out what to write
and how to write and present material
that will be successful as well in
theory so that's a that's a valuable
function as well but the main function
is helping them get work and then
negotiating their their deals and the
business side of their careers and
maximizing that as well which most of us
writers wouldn't be so good at doing
that for ourselves what's your advice to
a screenwriter who doesn't have an agent
or manager in two parts how should they
find one and what should they be doing
in the mean
when there's no active leads so there's
no real easy or direct or obvious way
for a writer to get an agent or a
manager it's what every writer wants
once they recognize that that's the
first step to having a career or to
working professionally pretty much
everyone knows that's what they need but
it's very hard to get one and you can't
just go make that happen so it's more
that you have to like focus on the craft
and focused on the writing it's not so
much how do I get an agent or manager
it's how do I write something that an
agent or manager would like if they read
it that's the key thing that people you
know are best to focus on I think so you
can send query emails to some managers
and even some agents here's a logline of
a script I've written you don't know me
but do you want to read the script and
in theory that could get read and they
could say yes and then they could love
the script and there are a small number
of people that get signed that way very
small I would say but it does happen a
lot of places really legit bigger
management and agency agent companies
won't take those kind of unsolicited
queries won't ever respond to you etc
there's also the writing contests
competitions and fellowships and things
and some film festivals have writing
contests that if you do really well at
really prestigious ones there will be
some agents or managers that will
probably find you from that or you can
use that information to make a query
have a better chance that resulting in
them wanting to read something if you
say this was fifth in the Nicholl
fellowship last year obviously that's
gonna help but as far as what to do in
the meantime it's right I mean that's
your job is the writing not think of the
business side and all that stuff's the
business side that you can't really
control or force into existence
so it's write and get feedback and be
open and learn and study the craft and
keep writing and write lots of things
don't just spend a million years on one
thing but keep initiating new projects
and exploring new ideas and increasing
your understanding of the craft and
sharing your work with people that can
give you professional level feedback if
possible whether you're in a writing
program or you hire a private consultant
of some kind or happen to know somebody
that can give you that
that will be honest and helpful as
opposed to just like a friend who
doesn't really know what they're reading
and it's wouldn't gonna be nice so to
speak where is someone finding the
contact info for these agents or
managers IMDB Pro yeah I mean you could
find when I'm DB Pro but there's so many
companies is a little hard to sift
through and know which ones are which
which ones are legit which ones are big
and which ones are small I did a list of
managers that's available on my website
it's been like almost three years now
it's probably still mostly up to date
I've seen other websites that have you
know list of the top Hollywood
management companies and so forth so
once you know which ones are the legit
ones then you go to item DB Pro to find
their contact info in theory another way
to know who's legit is if you and this
is how I created my list partly is to
read read information about what spec
scripts have sold in a given year and
which managers represented those or
which scripts made the blacklist or made
some of these other big year-end lists
of screenplays that you can find online
and who are the managers of those agents
and those scripts that will tell you
that that's probably a fairly legit
manager become because if you just
search managers on IMDB Pro you're gonna
get thousands and most of them are not
really in a position probably to be
necessarily that helpful and the same
thing with agencies the writers guild on
their website has a list of franchised
writers guild agencies which right now
is a shorter list because you know
there's been this this standoff
negotiation where where most of the big
agencies including the four big ones
that represent 80% of working writers or
something like that writers aren't
dealing with them right now and everyone
said to like fire their agents so
probably many people would tell you that
you really want to be before this whole
dispute happen and maybe after it's over
the big four are the ones that have the
most power and some most writers
gravitate to one of those big four but
there are a lot of other smaller ones as
well some of which are very legit and
many of which are probably not really
going to be able to do much for you
necessarily so part of it is knowing
which ones are the legit ones and then
how do I contact them can I contact them
but the bigger point is realizing that
you probably can't do that much to force
your way into having a manager or an
agent it will sort of happen over time
if and when your work gets to the point
where it's being loved by the kind of
people that that read for the agencies
of the management company there's all
these coverage services online like spec
scout.com is a pretty good one where
these professional readers read and
evaluate scripts and if one does really
well the black list has a thing like
this too it goes up on their website and
in theory managers and agents can see it
but again the step is writing something
that the big contest and these kind of
services and professionals would love
first that's the really hard part that
most writers never get to the getting a
manager an agent once you've done that
is easy it's just really hard to get
yourself to that place so that's kind of
the less lesser of Evil's that's the
least of the writers problem the the
real problem is getting your work out
there and getting it good enough so that
somebody you have more than just one
option yeah the real challenge is
getting it good enough good is an
obviously a subjective thing but good
enough in the eyes of those kind of
people that's why I say write some of
those people would love if they read it
meaning managers or agents that's the
hard part not the getting it to them
once you've done it because if you've
written something those people would
love it's probably winning contests and
doing well on coverage services and you
probably already have friends that are
agents or friends I mean it's because
it's rare that people get to that level
and when they do they're probably
already on the insider like it's it's
sort of like the next logical step as
opposed to this reaching for this star
thing that you can't even fathom how to
get there it's rare that a writer would
have material that they would love if
you could get it to them but they have
no idea and it just seems impossible
it's usually you would have learned and
educated yourself by osmosis even about
all of that while writing if your
material was at the point where those
people would like it if they read it
which is why most of them will say don't
try to find us we'll find you
essentially
why is screenwriting so hard well is it
hard I guess I'll get philosophical
about it do you mean is it why is it
hard to succeed professionally at it or
why is it hard to actually write a
screenplay you know it's it's not hard
to write one it's hard to write one that
you could be paid for or that someone
would spend millions of dollars to make
a movie from and that's like in a way
it's kind of like saying why is creating
a multi-million dollar business so hard
well it's just obvious why it's hard
it's like it's rare it takes something
special both in the person and the idea
and the the the how you execute it and
all that like there's a lot that goes
into it it's kind of like that because
that's kind of what you're doing when
you create a screenplay or a pilot
you're creating you're creating a
business plan for like a multi-million
dollar business essentially that
someone's got to put millions of dollars
into so when you think of it that way
it's like of course that's hard because
whatever endeavor you were doing that
you were trying to achieve that result
with would be hard or I should say it
would be rare that you're successful or
it would take a lot of work or a lot of
time or a lot of education or a lot of
expertise or a lot of coaching or a lot
of failed attempts before you get to the
one that works and all that kind of
stuff right so to me it's like the same
thing with screenwriting but you could
view it like you know I'm learning how
to play the piano you know and I
hopefully enjoy the process of learning
and enjoy the process of playing what I
can play right now I don't expect to be
playing this to Carnegie Hall but I am
enjoying what I'm doing and I'm people
are hearing it and say oh that was
really good but I'm also aware that when
I read Aaron Sorkin script or you know
JJ Abrams or whatever oh I can't do what
they're doing but I want to so how do
they do it and what is different from
what they're doing from what I'm doing
and it becomes you know or just like I
listen to a great penis I can't do that
well how do they do you know it's a
learning growing process where if you're
successful you can be famous and rich
and have a incredible life or whatever
but like anything like that
there's gonna be very few people that
you know get to the Olympics out of all
the people doing gymnastics or whatever
so whether you know it's just a hard
rare competitive
Tournament type profession on a
professional level but hopefully you've
enjoy the process and you get something
from doing it so it becomes just a
calling and a daily practice and an
interest as opposed to this thing so
hard is when you focus on how hard it is
then it's kind of strangles the creative
process and the joy from it not that I
don't do that on a regular basis because
writers tend to you know do that but
it's helpful to think I don't have to is
that how you see it as a daily practice
I like that yeah I set aside time daily
for writing and I try to keep that
appointment and I'm also open to ideas
flowing in other parts of the day or the
week when I wasn't sitting down to write
but yeah it's a practice because it's
like it's rare that you have a day where
oh my god this was the greatest day of
writing ever and then the next day you
still feel it was great and six months
later that material or whatever you did
that day was so significant you're
really just doing a tiny little bit
you're putting one brick on an enormous
wall every day and some of those bricks
are gonna be taken down and replaced
with different bricks later maybe all of
them and so you kind of just have to be
like I'm just doing what's in front of
me to do today this is today's task and
I know at least that I can do this or I
know how to start on doing this and I'm
just gonna do this and that's it or I
make it a little further but and it's
just every day you're doing that day's
work so just as let's say meditation is
a daily practice somebody's showing up
to meditate if they have an altar at
home or whatever it is for an hour
they're taking time they're making this
sort of sacred space for themselves
do you consider writing in the similar
things yeah and those two things go
together I meditate as well and
meditating right before writing session
is not a bad because definitely it helps
to not have your kind of surface mind
going kind of crazy and meditation can
help calm that and writing goes better
when that is calmed so yeah I do see it
as kind of similar to that in a way
when should a writer quit their
full-time job only when writing has
become one that can replace that
full-time job basically I would say
which you know is you kind of know it
when that happens I think I mean
obviously if you have a full-time job
because you need that amount of income
and you can't get it if you quit because
writing isn't isn't bringing it then I
probably wouldn't be quitting I mean I
think most people tend to get I don't
see people quitting their jobs even when
they have a nibble a professional nibble
at writing because you can have a nibble
that doesn't turn into anything even you
get an agent even you get a job even if
you get a job on writing staff of a hit
show that could be over in six months
and you may not get another one so I
mean you're gonna suspend your full-time
day job while you're on that hit show
because you probably have to go to work
every day on the show at the offices you
know with the rest of the writers but I
would say it's great if you have other
ways to earn a living that you like and
that have growth potential and no reason
to let those go but there may come a
time where you have to stop because I'm
writing on a movie and they need me you
know full-time for the next six months
they're paying me half a million dollars
or whatever that'd be a good problem
what about the notion that people think
that I just need six months gonna take
this time off and I'm gonna this is
gonna go great I'm gonna get up everyday
and I have this regimen and this
practice I'm gonna crank these pages out
do you think that really works or you
think that it's just this wrong romantic
version of writing I I don't know if it
works I've never really done that it may
be work sometimes for some people I'm
more believer that you carve out time in
your regular life every day or like five
days a week so if that means getting up
early for an hour
I mean Ron Bass used to be a lawyer and
he would wake up I the story was at 3
a.m. and right for four hours and then
go be an entertainment lawyer all day
back before he was a famous screenwriter
but even you know an hour at night an
hour at whatever 1/2 hour you know every
Saturday and Sunday for two hours each
and then although even that I think is
not as good as five days a week but the
idea of how I'm gonna go take this time
off and then when that time is over I
don't have time to write anymore I don't
thing tends to work as well that's what
this say you can't take a retreat for a
week or a month or I think John August
does that he goes to a hotel in Las
Vegas to pump out a first draft in three
weeks or whatever like a change of
scenery or getting away from the normal
daily responsibilities can work but I
think it works best combined with you
also have a daily writing practice and
you're moving it forward every day in
some way as well do you think the notion
of wanting to take this long stretch of
time out actually is damaging because
you lose touch with the day-to-day
because when you're not working or
you're like on vacation your mind is not
really in the reality of the day-to-day
your troubles are different your your
your you know what I'm saying cuz you're
you're not stressing being on someone
else's time schedule which you really
are when you have a job you're at the
mercy of their scheduling pretty much so
you think you lose touch with with
writing well you're saying when you go
off and write and leave your regular
life while you're writing not be as good
because you're out of touch with regular
life I don't really see that as an issue
I think it's okay to not be currently
immersed in your normal life to be able
to write I think it's just more a danger
that somebody just never writes until
they have that magical stretch of time
where they think they're gonna write all
day every day and it's going to be great
I think most writers who are
professionals tend to more have a block
of time they do it kind of every day
that maybe a shorter block but they're
always kind of doing it and moving it
forward